hi Ted thank you with more than 300 000
students Clark County School District is
the fifth largest in the entire nation
some say it's just too big and want to
break it up into several smaller
districts earlier today signature
signatures were submitted to possibly
move forward with a plan to do just that
Sasha loft is live from CCSD
headquarters to explain
Brian this is an initiative that's been
talked about for decades but this latest
plan looks like it has the traction to
possibly break up CCSD we spoke to some
for and against the idea tonight
Cameron Clark has two kids in the Clark
County School District I know they've
talked about this for years and years
he's one of many parents for the latest
initiative that could break it up I am a
big supporter of creating more local
control on Wednesday
should have submitted more than two
who opt out of their County school
districts and form their own at least
140 000 of these signatures must be
verified to qualify divided across the
state's four congressional districts
when you really think about it that's
going to take years to implement
superintendent Dr Jesus Jara and the
Clark County Education Association both
release statements against this plan Dr
Jara saying dismantling CCSD will raise
the cost to educate our children with
ccea claiming a move like this would
exacerbate the gross Equity that already
exists I would support the evaluation of
it on the flip side governor-elect Joe
Lombardo told politics now host John
langler last February he's all for a
discussion it's hard for any individual
to control something is overwhelming or
wielding as the Clark County School
District Cameron says no matter what
happens he hopes to see a change that
benefits his kids they're more localized
the people who are making decisions are
the more they will understand the needs
of those students
signatures are very that initiative
would go to the Nevada legislature in
2023 now the initiative would become law
if lawmakers approve it but if no action
is taken or if it's rejected then it
would go to a as a ballot option to
voters in 2024. reporting live tonight
Sasha Loftus 8 News Now